joining me now is Stephen Miller founder
of America First legal and former senior
advisor to president Trump Molly
Hemingway she's the editor-in-chief of
the Federalist and a Fox News
contributor and Chris Bedford executive
editor of the upcoming Common Sense
magazine all thanks for joining me I
appreciate it Molly uh to you first do
you buy the idea that Democrats might be
willing to throw throw Joe Biden under
the bus here
I think it really does depend at this
point we don't know what we don't know
about what documents are there we don't
know how bad this situation is and the
Department of Justice seems to be being
pretty gentle with him right now they've
put on the special counsel but it has a
very limited scope they've been very
friendly with him about you know
unveiling this document dispute and so
if the Democrats decide that it's time
for Joe Biden to go I have no doubt that
the Department of Justice will make life
very difficult for him but I don't know
if we have that information yet so Chris
you know I look at how what Hillary
Clinton did right she she used bleach
but she got rid of her emails it kind of
worked for her so if you have classified
documents at Joe Biden's house the FBI
allegedly isn't looking for them and
National Archives don't even know
they're missing why didn't they burn
them why didn't they Shred the documents
but instead of doing that they're like
aha we got documents we're going to turn
them over to the Department of Justice
and National Archives it seems like
someone knew those doc documents were
there and are trying to trap Joe Biden
so he can't run in 2024 but that's just
my tin foil hat take
well that's what I've been thinking too
my whole question this whole time has
been Qui Bono now when the midterms are
coming around everybody was expecting
Republicans to make serious gains and
Joe Biden to end up looking very very
weak everyone knows that Joe Biden was a
compromised candidate in the first place
someone who was chosen because he was
less wacky than his competitors but
wasn't the first choice of democratic
voters and these things returned or
these documents returned over the
Department of Justice after years and
years and years of sitting there just
days before the election the election
didn't go the way that some Democrats
actually and most people expected it to
go and at the end that ball had already
started rolling things started to go and
things were starting to move an
investigation was started and now it's
out of hand I'm wondering if this was an
internal hit against Joe Biden because
the whole time whenever I look at when
you talk about hypocrisy when you talk
about double standards those are just
words that powerless people use to
criticize those who are actually in
power Democrats are completely in power
they decide a lot of the wet times who
gets prosecuted who goes to prison who
doesn't so when Joe Biden gets in
trouble for this just before the midterm
I I really start to wonder who's
benefiting yeah no doubt about that
Stephen I had to save this very special
moment from for from jensaki just for
you watch this
so this argument that this very
different case of Biden's classified
documents is going to be a political
problem for him doesn't hasn't really
even played out on the other side and I
think that's important to note because
the difference as you said is who's
defending democracy and the answer to
that is pretty clear yeah so Stephen
they're trotting out the defending
democracy defense again is that going to
work Stephen
no it's not going to work trying to spin
Joe Biden's theft of classified
documents and his family's illicit
connections to foreign governments like
China as a defense of democracy is a
great insult to the intelligence of
every single American voter and if
that's the best argument they can come
up with then they are in serious trouble
you had James Comer head of the
oversight committee on just a few
minutes ago he is going to drill down
into this thing and get to the very rock
bottom of it because there are key
questions that have to be asked for
example why did the Biden Center at the
University of Pennsylvania where there
was a stash of classified documents
receive
indirectly all these funds from China
right China gave money to the University
of Pennsylvania and then money from the
University of Pennsylvania starts
flowing into the pockets of Joe Biden
and the Biden Center what was going on
there whatever it was it is shady as all
all get out and I am convinced that once
enough subpoenas are issued once enough
investigations are launched what we are
going to find is going to shock people
no no doubt about that um so so Molly
activist Chuck Todd put on his I'm a I'm
a journalist hat for a while watch this
Senator do you have a crime that you
think Hunter Biden committed because
I've yet to see anybody explain it is
not a crime to make money off your last
name
so Chuck you ought to read the Marco
Polo report where they detail all kinds
of potential crimes you know Senator
grass
potentials I'll take your word that
you're ethically bothered by Hunter
Biden I'm curious though you seem to
have a power are you not uh I'm a
journalists
Molly truck is absolutely unhinged what
do you think here well Chuck Todd is not
a journalist first of all he spent years
pushing the Russia collusion hoax which
was this deranged conspiracy theory that
Donald Trump had won the election by
colluding with with Russia to steal the
election and he would come on day after
day week after week and berate anybody
who didn't share his conspiracy thinking
and now when we're actually dealing with
Hunter Biden who's under real
investigation who uh you know we already
know that he had problems paying taxes
again the Department of Justice was very
friendly about letting him repay some of
the taxes that he that he had failed to
pay he's got gun issues that he's dealt
with drug issues prostitution issues
he's been working with foreign oligarchs
and corrupt regimes across the world and
now you know with all of that there that
we know about all of a sudden Chuck Todd
says I don't think we should rush to
judgment he has done nothing but rushed
to judgment for years and it's really
one of these things too I think
Republicans need to think about whether
they should even you know be on a show
where you have some sort of deranged
conspiracy theorist like that he has
shown himself to be operating in such
bad faith for so long there's really no
need to treat him like a legitimate
person you know I agree with that stop
going on these left-wing programs
because they're not media personalities
they're actually activists for the
Democrat Party but Chris to that point
it seems like these these media outlets
and their personalities are more
defensive of Joe Biden than even
Democrats are of Joe Biden
and remember the media the media ran
President Biden's campaign for him he
didn't even go out there they had these
weird scenes where he would sit inside
of his basement or somewhere I didn't
have cars turning their headlights on
and off because people were too afraid
they ran that for him they ran cover for
Hunter Biden the whole time they turned
on the New York Post they were in favor
of censorship they worked with the
government ended up working with with
social media companies like Twitter to
suppress that story without anything
ever coming out and here you have Chuck
Todd saying why investigative there's no
crud now David her son he's got a great
piece right now at the Federalists
saying well you investigate to find out
what's going on we know that there's
corruption we know that he was dealing
with foreign powers we know that he was
on drugs we know that he was paying uh
50 000 a month in rent to his dad with
all these uh living there where all
these classified documents were in the
garage maybe it's worth poking around on
that yeah I know it's worth poking
around a little bit but you know we're
speaking of hacks and so here's Joe
Scarborough
transparency I think works best for the
Biden Administration and works best for
Biden himself because they find the
documents they report it immediately if
for a different situations than Donald
Trump's anybody who says it's not is a
political hack you know so Stephen we
heard from Professor trolley that you
know in our in our first block that this
explanation it doesn't work it doesn't
wash
well it doesn't work on 45 different
levels not the least of which is that
Joe Biden entered the White House 14
years ago yeah 14 years ago he left the
White House in 2017. using these
documents were just suddenly discovered
something somebody some entity someone
with an interest decided to get these
documents out into the public like now
we'll have to figure out through the
house oversight committee and others who
that person was why it happened but now
you have Biden's lawyers working in
secret to present documents in this
highly choreographed fashion there's
clearly clearly a cover-up involved here
preventing us from seeing why these
documents were stolen who had access to
them who benefited from these documents
how does this involve the pay for play
scheme the bottom family wasn't involved
in these are serious crimes that
threaten National Security
and I think it's always important to
remember that when these two cases are
compared Biden and Trump Donald Trump
had the ability to declassify his
documents Joe Biden had no ability to
declassify his documents panel thanks
for that Insight I appreciate it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else